top model victoria janke ist nach
südamerika ausgewandert ist zu ihrem
freund nach sao paulo gezogen doch dann
brach krone aus so stark wie ihn nur
wenigen anderen ländern seit dem sitzt
die gebürtige hamburgerin dort fest und
sie ist mir jetzt live zugeschaltet
guten abend frau janke vielleicht können
sie uns einen einblick geben in
brasilien wie ist das dort aktuell unter
corona also hier ist in sao paulo und
hier ist absoluter lockt dann ist es ist
alles geschlossen
die leute müssen zu hause bleiben und ja
ich verlasse eigentlich gut wie gar
nicht ja das zuhause sei den papieren
auftrag setzen auch im brasilianischen
tv und hat den shooting für burg
brasilien aber natürlich auch unter den
ganzen bedingungen jeder hat so eine
maske getragen hens in italien und
brasilien ist natürlich auch noch mal
die sache man kann wirklich einfach mal
so spazieren gehen auch wegen der
sicherheit und ja es ist auf jeden fall
anders sagen wir es mal so aber man
gewöhnt sich auch irgendwie 3 nach 3
monaten ja versucht mal das beste draus
machen und warum konnten sie nicht
einfach zurück nach deutschland fliegen
also ich habe eine immunschwäche
krankheit und wiegen für mich ist immer
ein sehr großes risiko und auch wegen
den lockdown gegen die ganzen flügel
nicht so normal wie sie sollten und ich
warte auf jeden fall gegen block kaum
noch ab und muss dann aber auch schon
wegen meiner gesundheit natürlich möchte
mich jetzt kein risiko aussetzen sagen
wir es mal so gerade auch bei die
infektionszahlen hier sehr sehr kurz
sind und wenn man sich liegt es
natürlich das risiko noch vier gehört
dass man sich ansteckt
welche maßnahmen gibt es denn in
brasilien sie haben gerade schon
angesprochen den lockt aber vielleicht
können es noch ein bisschen genauer
beschreiben was dürfen sie was dürfen
sie nicht
brasiliens natürlich auch die polizei
greift hier ein bisschen härter durch
dann wird man so zum beispiel in rio de
janeiro
man darf auch nicht an die strände gehen
sobald leute an den stränden kommt die
polizei räumt die leute so zusammen vom
strand weg polizeigewalt ist natürlich
noch mal anders und sonst ja man sollte
eine maske tragen keine masten pflicht
aber die leute halten sich schon sehr
daran also zumindest die die leute in
den höheren schichten die die ärmeren
menschen in dem verbände zum beispiel
wie instagram sie können sich gar keine
maske leisten dadurch steigen die zahlen
bei den ärmeren menschen natürlich
extrem
und man muss halt aufpassen weil man
kann es natürlich jetzt ja auch nicht so
differenzieren die die menschen arbeiten
teilweise auch in den supermärkten oder
auf der straße und deswegen muss man
halt für sich selbst sehr aufpassen
ja also das sind wir also die sachen die
die und die anderen menschen die können
auch nicht zu hause bleiben weil wenn
die eine woche lang nicht arbeiten gehen
dann verhungern geht die können sich
kein essen kauf also die leute müssen
arbeiten gegen dass es da noch mal ein
bisschen anders und die leute werden sie
auch nicht finanziell vom staat
unterstützung wie es in deutschland zb
der fall war
vielen dank frau anke und alles gute ihn